what I was looking at was her Instagram
I was like she's married to a world
famous pop star yeah and I know she's a
model right but he's a girl at that
point but he's he's got groupies yeah
and he's also very religious apparently
I don't know what's going on so it's
like you're married to a world famous
pop star and you still got
look at look at the booty one look at it
yeah look at that yeah okay and the
funny thing is he comments on it as well
so it's bizarre as long as he's okay
with it he's like oh my God would she be
okay with it if he wants to be
commenting under somebody else's post no
would she be okay I think it works one
of two ways like you can't you can't
take one side just because one's a
female and then you're not back the
other side like true pick your own
battles all all the same but don't don't
come at the man for cheating if she's
gonna put it out there as if she's gonna
cheat as well well interesting though
you say that well I just think of it as
like like mating strategies like women
want to get attention from high status
men that's Instagram
men want to screw as many people as
possible so like how many I don't know
anyone that got married and closed their
Instagram I don't know anyone that did
it like my age anyway actually I told
you're right so yeah so I'm saying
modern women are shitty ones why would
she close your Instagram I don't
understand that because it's advertising
[Laughter]
[Music]
You could argue Justin Bieber's job is
to screw groupies on tour yeah
the model what it's different he's not
he's not a model right so I do get what
you're saying it's a world famous pop
star
the world famous pop stars to do they
screw groupies on the tour
bro's oldest time
of the job yeah it is
that's Chris Brown do on state come on
yeah yeah and you know you could just
tell she would have none of that if he
was doing that yeah but it's like we
we're a society where men aren't told
they can do that they're controlling if
they tell a girl to close her Instagram
but women immediately want you to stop
sleeping with other girls and you can
tell like I know so many people in
relationships who've told people
unfollow her stop liking her Shadows I
know get rid of her but if you do it to
a man or if you're in a relationship
with another girl and you tell her not
to do that you're the bad person well
you've got to be careful it goes one or
two like you have to look see I think
that's a standard respect thing
but if you're gonna do it one way and
not accept it backwards yeah but there's
different hold on hold on I feel this
might be controversial but I feel like
there are different
um there are different reasons and
there's people with different
circumstances for example if there was
if you was dating someone and she was
for example like a content creator or
something and she had she was in you
know Instagram engagement groups so if
she was an engagement group in an
engagement group There are rules you
have to like everyone's photo to help
each other with the algorithm right so
would you then turn around to your
girlfriend and say to her I don't want
you liking pictures of other guys the
standard person isn't honestly like I'm
not famous
but would a good wife argue with him
when he asks that and say well but my
Instagram grouper would she just say
okay whatever you say honey yeah in a
really traditional setup that she she
would give it up probably yeah you know
she would if she's making six figures
well regardless of no Rick and William
regardless of if he's making six figures
she should be like listen you know we're
married now that is the I've made this
commitment in the in the eyes of the
Lord exactly and in the eyes of God so
that's more important to me than having
Instagram account you know that's what
she would have said in the back of the
day okay so I have a question why does
he have to be making six figures to have
to be listened to and do you have the
same energy if a woman's Med does she is
she if she's average looking does she
not is she not able to ask for loyalty
um that's a good question but you know
she's average looking so why why does
she get to ask for that yeah
I don't know I I don't really know how
to answer that because I just feel like
women do definitely look at Men's
financial status and we can sit here and
argue about that all the time but at the
end of the day there is survival and
women will always try to go with someone
above her level or at least on her level
she will never go low so you said six
figures
that's 10 a month no I know I was just
trying to be funny there but like
um no but I'm just saying like
realistically she will always go above
or on the same level so she's never
gonna go low so financial status does
get looked at and that is actually how
men earn respect from women I feel like
it's one of the ways that if you want to
earn respect from a woman you need to do
that you need to be a making bank yeah
no brokies
how much does he have to make what about
an average guy
um
I don't know I don't know what the
average salary here is what is it like
40 30. depends on your age so like 25
year olds gonna be earning like 35
000. all right which in London isn't
going to be very much in in the
standards of learning six figures
and then it's on it's unfair to expect
that off someone
you've got the average you've got the
average UK wage though which is probably
like it's going to be weighted higher in
London yeah yeah because you've got
extremities you've got you know if
you're looking at the mean it's going to
be taking both things does the man
expect us to be top 10 20 30 of beauty
no but why should they not if we're
expecting them to be in the highway I
think they do want that yeah they might
want it but they're not they're not
going to hold out for it because most
guys are quite thirsty do you know what
I mean we'll talk about this the other
night most guys are quite thirsty
they're going to take what they could
get you know oh oh yeah I mean that's a
good point it's a good point have you
heard the husband's store analogy no oh
there's like I hope I say this right
there's like a husband store analogy in
the manosphere okay and basically every
every store or every floor
is a different set of husbands okay and
you go up before
um then the only rules you can't go back
down so there's five floors total and
you you can go up but you can't go down
so the first floor is guys that love
kids
yeah and our and our loyal to you oh
sweet and so the women go to the first
floor so they go to the first floor and
they say you know what I want more I
wanna I wanna go up so they go to the
second floor and then they fight they
should do one no no no no it gets better
it gets better so these guys love kids
they're loyal and they're hot oh they're
sexy yeah
floor okay then they get just curious
yeah yeah so they go what's what's next
curiosity they say they say okay the
next floor these guys are hot
they make 70 000 a year they love kids
and they're loyal
but she's on the third floor and she's
like well what's what what's happening
what's on the next floor and so back at
it then she goes next they make six
figures
love kids loyal
everything but she wants to go to the
fifth floor and on the fifth there's a
to us on Facebook all the husbands
are sold out
I love the dogs because die alone
I mean so so that to make it fair they
did a wife score or a wife score right
so on the first floor there's women good
sex loyal
sixes and they never found out was it
what was on the second floor
yeah good enough
I think modern day woman no offense and
I know I'm a woman but are super like
materialistic I don't agree
I love most of my friends but I know if
they were given the opportunity to go
with someone who aren't like over a
million they would take it and they'll
cheat on the person that they love and
they feel committed to and that's such
an issue well they cheat for money
yeah yeah yeah
[Music]
but it's been normalized it's seen as
normal now to cheat and it seemed as
normal to like be like oh yeah but he's
better
why why not just fight them through
finally better because he have money
exactly why is it why is that important
exactly and that's why guys shouldn't
get married because that's the dynamic
that's the dynamic but you're as a guy
you're entering into a contract with
somebody when that is the dynamic that's
going on in society and that's very
problematic because you're you're
basically marrying into it's like it's
like buying a house that it's got loads
of faults with the house and you're
going to have loads of money to pay
further down the line it's like you're
buying you're getting into a contract
with somebody who is being influenced by
the society that's basically saying to
you there's always going to be better
there's always your and not only is that
always going to be better but you
deserve better you know you go girl you
go on to the next dude just one more and
more yeah
why is that worth it my Grandma had 13
kids for a fireman and she submitted to
him and that's that's the thing like
modern that's a good job but that's
beautiful that is what it should be it
was an average salary back then and so
I'm I'm just saying like you know what
is this generation this generation is
just getting worse but but money
shouldn't be the end and it is what it
is
if you feel that emotionally attached to
someone like if you're someone like me
that doesn't want to particularly get
married if you feel that emotionally
attached that you're willing to get
married you should not just up and leave
because someone else has more money or
someone else maybe is more attractive
like it should be all taken as I've
committed to this person for a reason
there was something there unless there's
something a lot deeper going on like
abuse or or something it's a lot deeper
and it's a lot more complex if it's
something as simple as that person earns
more I'm gonna go with them
so do you think that the woman so would
you say you think that the woman should
stick it out basically even if there is
like a period of suffering not
necessarily stick out but don't if it
works say this man that she's with is
like literally not hardly making any
money they are really struggling like
times are really tough for her and do
you think that she should just stay and
stick it out or do you think she should
want better for herself
all right
um
I take you for my lawfully wedded
husband
all right for better for worse for
richer or for poorer and sickness and
health till death do us part if you
believe in leaving the second there's a
rough patch you might get married
at that point oh that boy but that's all
Boomer stuff that Bible
oh my God but the whole point is like if
if you believe in divorce then why get
married there's no point just be in a
relationship because you're not a wife I
mean you you getting married and then
you think oh I'm gonna divorce one day
that's why they're on some prenups
though because it's like well I don't
think anyone wants to get divorced when
they get married they think it's forever
but I think things happen yeah and you
have to be realistic that but that's I'm
not saying that maybe you marry someone
and in the beginning it's all good and
then suddenly when you get married he
might lose his money and then leave him
no I don't agree with that but I feel
like yeah I feel like you should still
stay with that person but if there's no
progress there's no sign of him you know
working hard or trying we're trying to
get back to that level that he was at
before you know it's time to call it
quick this is what that's one more time
one more time
Better or For Worse for richer for
poorer yeah and sickness and in health
until death do us anyways that's it this
is what Massey the the author of the
rational male who talks a lot about this
kind of these kind of intergenerative
Dynamics he talks about the burden of
performance on men and that's exactly
what you're talking about then there's
always this there's this burden of
performance on men it's like okay well
he could have a rough patch but if he
doesn't shape up after two years you
know she's gonna be like thinking well
hang on what's going on which is
all right I understand why you would say
that but that is contrary to what Pearl
right now because the agreement is For
Better or Worse for sicker and poorer
because it could be he's got some
underlying issue like he's got maybe
some underlying like like depression or
something like that he's trying to deal
with some trouble and he's not working
he's not pushing himself to the degree
because of that but you know the the
woman who disregards that could just say
well solid you know I'm gonna go for
Steve over here because he's making six
figures so I have a question so the same
way you believe that
um if he's not making more money or
working or whatever you should leave
should he leave her if she gets fat
[Laughter]
I'm just asking yes
um
I think he's he's allowed to to bring it
up yeah for sure
we're gonna give her some chance you
know to get in the gym she got like
three months six months oh well no
because she's not gonna leave him like
if the woman is like in that situation
she's not we're not saying the woman's
just gonna go right oh you're not
working for three months off I go like
it's not gonna happen like that she's
obviously gonna stick it out she's gonna
try and help especially if you've got
kids it's different like she may not be
able to go back to work they may have to
find alternative ways of surviving I
don't know it's very difficult but she's
not going to leave straight away it's
it's you know over a few years three
four years maybe I don't know
um and in the same yeah same energy for
for the man as well if the woman's
completely let herself go and you know
she's not taking care of herself forget
the man it's not even good for you as a
woman forget him like it's about you
like you want to be able to look
yourself in the mirror and feel
confident and happy and you know
comfortable in your skin so go out and
do something about it so I yeah but he
have to make sure you you get like some
compliments about it yeah so it can make
you feel better but are you going to
give him the same compliments if he has
no job oh yeah yeah you know what I mean
I have a question do you Journey I'm
gonna help him do you genuinely think
most women nicely ask or do you think
most women nag let's just
okay baby I'm so happy you didn't do
that thing I asked you to do last week
yeah very happy
the woman condition yeah
be away but the female condition is very
different to a man as well like we we do
like to
the offense but picket things yeah
whereas a man will be very much more
upfront about it and if they have an
issue or something most of the time most
of the time not all men I I know not all
men are quite as straightforward as that
but most men will just say it as it is
whereas women will sugarcoat things and
kind of kind of be straightforward it
makes it more complicated so if you
can't take it don't give it as many of
you know I was just banned on Tick Tock
and we are demonetized on a daily basis
on this platform if you want to help
please consider sending a super thanks
below every donation helps and it helps
make what we do possible